while most americans have put their cova
concerns in the rear view mirror not
everybody is ready to move on more than
1 300 new york times employees are
refusing to return to the office three
days a week while demanding raises of
more than 13 percent with no mandatory
return until next summer the workers
also expressing their distaste after the
times gave employees branded lunch boxes
this week as a return to office perk
and elite college campuses across the
country like nyu and georgetown still
have some form of an indoor mask mandate
in place dana i heard a little chuckle
there was that at the lunch boxes
you know i think if i was at the new
york times and they sent me a lunch box
so i'd like okay well guys you're not
really getting the point they had over a
thousand employees writing comments
basically saying inflation is killing
them like oh well you could put that on
the front page yes
that might be something like they're
really saying i think that inflation
obviously is taking a bite also i
believe that
commutes are an issue our infrastructure
is not kept up people don't people are
realizing well wait if i can be home and
get there in time for the little league
game and i'm doing my job just fine why
do i have to be in the office now i'm
actually a proponent of being in the
office i think there's a lot of benefit
to it but i understand where these
people are coming from but my last point
is another problem is the open plan
office
people are going crazy because they
can't stand listening to all of their
colleagues conversations and the noises
and everything and companies go back and
forth they'll do individual offices and
then they'll go to open plan individual
offices open plan bloomberg when he was
running for president said he was going
to make the west wing open plan and i
said oh he's going to lose
and perhaps that's why he lost greg you
hate listening to people i do i hate
yeah and it's all you know obviously
it's jesse's staff that drives me crazy
but it must be hard for the new york
times to write about uh downplaying
inflation now when their old staff is
rebelling over inflation and also think
about the jobs that people show up to
and die
right they're like these people want to
stay home because they feel unsafe maybe
they might get covered talk to a logger
or a deep sea fisherman they show up i
mean when an arts and culture editor
says you know i feel healthy if i just
stay home you know they should fire him
as an employer you cannot forfeit the
right to require people to come to work
right the problem is we've expanded the
idea of health to encompass so many
things from gun ownership to the use of
gender pronouns now that anybody could
say like i don't feel healthy and you by
requiring me to come to work kind of
puts me at risk this is a luxury protest
these people don't make life work right
they're not truck drivers electricians
plumbers could you imagine a plumber
working from home
you need like a zoom snake like a zoom
snake to go into your toilet or maybe
you'd have to like people would have to
come to you with your clogged plumbing
you have to carry your toilet to the
plumber that would not work
no it wouldn't you know one of one of
the interesting thing is that there's
more unionizing now because they're
saying look you know
you're you're asking us to do more
you're asking us now to spend money on
gas on lunches on clothing everything's
more expensive for us to come to work
and that's not in our contract that we
have to come to work because nobody ever
thought to put it in the contract i mean
usually you got a job you came to work
and like dana i mean i think we all need
to be here but you know i kind of get it
but but the unionizing i think is going
to create a real power struggle with
management but the unions you have to
think about it it's it's not
management's fault that we're in this
mess you know it's china's fault that
we're in this mess because because of
covet and now people got a little lazy
they got a little comfortable whatever
it might be i don't know but it's a
shame because management now is saying
look you get your butt to work a goldman
sachs or you get your butt fired and
that's okay too
i do think that's okay is that
yeah i mean there's two types of people
in this world they're the people that
enjoyed the pandemic protocols and then
there's the rest of us that wanted to
get back to normal it just so happens
that all the people that liked being
locked down are in academia and in the
media they're shy people they enjoy
submitting to the government and they
like self-righteously judging other
people who don't submit to the
government so that whole concept of
being home alone felt comfortable for
them because it's a big scary world for
a lot of these introverts and they're
trying to lock in this like permanent
mole mentality and the rest of us are
looking at them like a bunch of weirdos
i mean you need a lunchbox to show up to
work come on
to spend a day in your mind would be
interesting oh i have no idea i think i
do i went to brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now